but some las vacanze are not cutting the  mayor any slack there is another effort  underway to recall mayor Goodman this  time from a former professional poker  player I spoke to Doug Polk earlier  tonight who just hours ago was notified  by the city clerk of what he needs to do  to get her removed from office when you  elect someone they should represent you  and they should represent having your  best interests at heart and and having  they should also have a responsibility  to protect you that's that's what we  want from our politicians and we're not  getting back here so pulk plans to use  social media and this website called  recall Carolyn Goodman dot-com to get  the signatures he needs to move forward